hello everyone I hope you're all having
a good day and week and holiday season
um I wanted to do the by now annual uh
New Year's um video where we look back
on the past year and also look to some
degree into the future and see sort of
reflect on where we've been and where
we're
going um I want to begin as always by
saying thank you to everyone out there
who has been watching and engaging with
the content this has been another year
of of course of growth for the channel
but um above all and most importantly of
course where the community itself has
grown and become stronger uh I'm I'm
feel so honored to be part of of of this
community of of not just of fellow
content creators um on YouTube and other
platforms but also the wider Community
with the audience as well I think it's
it's just one of the one of the most
beautiful things and and and I love my
audience I think my audience is is
incredibly you guys I'm talking directly
to you I realize you guys are int
incredibly intelligent and kind um you
know I think I've said this before but
when you start a Channel about religion
which is such a contentious topic you
kind of expect the comment section to be
like a battlefield like a just a mess
and it really isn't
um most of the time at least you know
you guys are are
so kind to each other and intelligent
and there are wonderful interesting
discussions going on in the comments um
you are very supportive of me and and
each other all it's it's incred so I
just want to say thank you so much to
everyone in this community um for making
this channel what it is because without
you this this thing wouldn't exist right
it's all it's it's a collaborative
effort we're here to to learn and be
nerds together right we're here to you
know I may be the one speaking and and
you're the one listening but really it's
it's a sort of it's a venture of of
learning together right I'm learning as
much as you are as we're doing this so
it's it's a it's a beautiful thing so
thank you all so much uh a special thank
you of course also to my patrons over on
patreon.com who support the channel
monetarily also without whom this would
not be possible of
course so thank you to everyone who
supports this channel it's been a
wonderful year we've done a lot of
really fun stuff really cool stuff I
think the year started off with the big
neoplatonism collab U which was very
success very successful and very much
appreciated uh I always enjoy working
with with people that I admire and that
um make not
only inspire me in that way but also
make me a better person a better content
creator a better um whatever you want to
call it a better U public educator
perhaps um working together is one of
the greatest experiences uh of doing
this whole thing because this job can
get
somewhat um you know lonely sometimes uh
and to have such great people to work
with in the in the YouTube Community
like Justin Sledge from esoterica and
zis slavin secrets of unity um Andrew
Henry religion for breakfast Angela puka
from Angela Symposium I work together
with Dana trell from the modern
hermeticist um I worked with John Veri
on the on the neopenis collab um all of
these people that I've had the privilege
to work with over the year um
really you
know these you know working together
with such great people is one of the
things that makes this job
so rewarding and
so meaningful and and wonderful in
different ways so thank you all of the
people whom I've had the privilege to
work with over the year as well it's
been it's been a beautiful
experience uh this past year has also
been a year of of travel for me and um
again that's another thing that that
I've said that I wanted to do more is
sort of do on location stuff and I've
traveled we traveled quite a lot this
year we went to Tunisia in January um
and shot some great footage did a whole
documentary about Sufism in Tunisia and
again and I I I I say this a lot and and
I kind of continue to say it because it
really is true none of that would of
course be possible without your support
as well especially on my patreon so um
again thank you for that um so we did
documentary in Tunisia about the sufis
there uh beautiful exp got to meet some
some of the audience there too which was
wonderful uh a bit later we also
traveled to Spain to Andalucia southern
Spain to Seville and Cordoba and and got
some footage there as well in a similar
vein and the they were also beautiful
experiences I've said before I want to
to venture more into doing sort of
documentary stuff and on location uh
content and uh those were sort of some
test runs for what can be done with that
stuff and I think it went pretty
successfully above all it was a lot of
fun to gather my own footage like on
location I'm talking about this old
mosque or this saint and I'm standing in
the place where that happened it's a
different thing right than sitting at
home just talking about it and showing
you images that someone else took so I'm
going to definitely continue doing that
stuff in the future we have some plans
for for for future travels next year and
uh we'll see how that goes you never
know with the you know everything that's
going on in the world of
course but there are some plans for
Future travel and more documentary style
content like that for you to look
forward to and for me to look forward to
um of course during the summer we also
traveled to Amsterdam or to the
Netherlands um and I got to meet in
person some of my great colleagues
particularly
um Justin Sledge and Zi slavin and we
had a wonderful time there Justin was um
Justin was lecturing at the um the
embassy of the free mind in Amsterdam
and so we spent some time there together
and had a you know it's the first time
we meet in person and we just we' had
the best of times and also one of the
most beautiful moments from that trip
was getting to meet some um some people
from the audience too um we had a so
when Justin had his lecture there there
was sort of a we just hung out in the
garden uh it was a beautiful beautiful
moment a beautiful evening we're all
hanging out in the garden at the embassy
of the free mind there in Amsterdam
among the the books all the the old sort
of occult esoteric books in the in the
Ritman Library
upstairs and
uh and and I got to and we got to to
sort of meet some some some some some of
the audience members out there right we
going to uh had some beautiful
conversation and and it really showed um
some of those meetings some of those
conversation really showed us and we
talked about this afterwards that what
we do actually has an impact and that
was very meaningful to us um especially
meaning
some I don't think I'm going to name
names here we met some some some younger
um audience members some younger um
fellow um religious studies esoteric and
nerds um that really showed us that um
you know stuff you do on the internet
has an impact on people and that really
inspired us and continues to inspire us
and that was a very beautiful beautiful
moment then of course we met up with
Angela puka in in malma in Sweden for
the uh conference for for Western
terorism
there so for my own you know for my own
part uh it's been a continuing year of
of making content that I'm very proud of
we did the new Sufism video we did a big
episode on roomi that I've been thinking
about doing for a year years and years
and I finally got around to doing it uh
which came out really well um Safa who
read the song of the read uh very
beautifully in that video is also a
person I met in in that Garden um at the
embassy of the free mind and she gave me
a reading of Haz which yeah one of my
favorite moments of the Year probably so
thank you Safa also for for that reading
but also for the beautiful reading in
the roomi video in
particular um we did we sort of started
a series on on mysticism you could say
the starting with the new video on
Sufism continuing with the video on
Christian mysticism and the next video
the first video hopefully that's going
to come out this year next weekend is
going to be a sort of continuation of
that serious uh video on Jewish
mysticism so a big video and I'm going
to bring some of those friends I
mentioned along for the right too so
it's not just going to be focused on
cabala which is what most people think
of when they think of Jewish mysticism
but more Broad brly so it's a it's an
ambitious and long video so you can look
forward to that it's going to be really
fun in summary it's been a beautiful
year for the channel um had some
beautiful experiences traveling and
meeting colleagues friends and fans uh
and also just seeing this community grow
further has has just continuing
continued to inspire me to keep working
and keep uh putting content out there um
as many of you know also it's been a
year year where I've done some new music
I put out a new song recently called
ismos uh and I've continued to be active
on my other channel which is also
growing which is just under my own name
called Philip Palm so if you're
interested in my music stuff then
definitely go check out that channel I
plan to keep being active in terms of
that next year too there's going to be
some new music coming out um which I'm
very excited about so uh the future is
looking very exciting in in many ways I
have a lot of projects that I've been
working on that are sort of coming to
fruition in different ways and that's
that's that's very cool in terms of next
year my my aspirations my hopes are to
continue growing this channel of course
continuing to make music content over on
the other channel uh both putting out my
own music but also talking about music
so I do similar content there to what I
do here talking about you know religions
and philosophers and stuff but there I
talk about sort of um music and
musicians and composers and stuff like
that in a similar vein the topics
sometimes really the overlap so last one
I did was on bak and sort of bak's
metaphysics which could have been a let
religion video but I chose to do it
there the next one's going to be a video
about col train so John col train and
his sort of philosophy of music so I'm
doing similar stuff there to what I'm
doing here but with a more particular
focus on music as well as putting out my
own music so I'm going to keep trying to
um live in that world also next year a
bit more while still being being just as
active here on let's talk religion there
are some exciting projects in the works
like the one on Jewish mysticism I'm
doing a probably a remake of the zorran
video for from a few years ago both
because know the production value of my
videos have gotten better so I want to
do a just a better looking and sounding
video on zor asterism but also because
both the research in general and my
knowledge of the topic has certainly
increased so there is some there's some
stuff that can definitely be updated
with that um we're going to continue
exploring more stuff in in Sufism and
mysticism different philosophers um all
the stuff that you're used to uh we're
going to keep chugging along with all of
that content as well hopefully as More
Travel content so not travel Vlogs but
like like we've done last year like
documentary style videos about maybe
different locations
maybe people but like child on location
like the one in in Tunisia or the one in
ceville for example so um I hope to see
you uh next year I'm looking forward to
it I hope you are too uh thank you all
again so so much I really am so honored
to be doing this it's it's it's a dream
job in many ways to be able to
just learn and talk about the stuff that
I'm passionate about and have people to
do it with both in terms of the audience
you guys but also all of my wonderful
colleagues and fellow uh content
creators that um that I admire and that
that inspire me so much uh so thank you
all so much if you want to follow me on
my socials I will leave the stuff here
or something um there was a Twitter
thing and I'm I'm on Tik Tok I'm on
Instagram you can follow those if you
want to um check out my other channel
again Philip Palm if you want to know
sort of my music there's going to be a
link tree also if you want to find all
the different links to my stuff in the
description
I have a website too that's also going
to be there um
anyway above all happy New Year everyone
I hope the year has treated you well and
been meaningful in different ways um
even if it has been if it hasn't been
the the best year sometimes we have good
years sometimes we have bad years but
hopefully there has been stuff that you
have uh learned from the experiences of
this year whether they be good or bad um
and that has been meaningful to your
life in some way that I think is the
most important thing uh certainly uh you
guys being there has been very
meaningful to me so I hope next year
holds a lot of meaning and Beauty for
you as well and happy New Year everyone
happy New Year everyone and I'll see
you I'll see you next
[Music]
year